ne se serait pas habillé à coup sûr mais aujourd'hui
plus que jamais je pense que c'est de retour
être la couleur du drapeau et non la couleur d'un
cassé
mais grâce à la Coupe maintenant nous sommes
récupérer notre drapeau maintenant pour
notre drapeau n'est plus une fête
politicien ne représente plus aucun
politicien représente notre nous sommes
Les Brésiliens et moi sommes venus le voir imprimé ici
avec le drapeau du Brésil parce que j'ai
très fier de notre pays
[Musique]
Donc, les gens recadrent ces
couleurs du drapeau et t-shirt
L'équipe brésilienne a commencé à émerger comme
une tendance dans les réseaux sociaux qui a été
appelé brasilcor, c'est comme si nous
avait le Brésil dans le cœur et voulait
le manifester en retour
[Musique]